my guest tonight's a very funny comedian
who hosts planets come live on Twitch as
well as the podcast beautiful anonymous
please welcome our very good friend he's
my surrogate son Chris Gethard how are
you Chris I'm good I had no idea that
the adoption went through that's awesome
it did go through you are now my son and
I expect you to care for me and carry me
to the toilet in about five years when
I'm no longer able to walk on my own
I can't wait who's gonna tell my my old
dad you or me who's gonna go I've
notified your father he's fine with it
he said good riddance right no I'm you
know it's it's a question I never asked
before we all went into quarantine but
now I do ask people how are you just
unlike the most basic level how are you
doing update me on your well-being I'm
I'm good I mean everybody in my sphere
is healthy and safe so I really thank
God for that my situation is basically I
lived in Jackson Heights Queens which
was they call it the epicenter of the
epicenter I lived a few blocks from the
homeowners hospital oh wow yeah yeah so
in my neighborhood it really got hit
hard we had been planning on moving
anyway though we bought a house in New
Jersey few months ago so we were like
let's just move
we got a one-year-old son but
unfortunately our co-op board in Queens
would not allow movers in so we couldn't
move to our new house so for the past
two months I've been in a very very
small house in upstate New York it's me
my wife our one-year-old my
mother-in-law and her dog so Oh ideal I
would say it's ideal oh you're an answer
Wow
my my my condolences my hat's off my
respect you're going through a lot right
now you are it for the one year old yeah
it is he learned to walk while we were
up here and then just instantly learned
how to run it was so quick I think it's
that's why as well yeah yeah it's funny
they they child will learn to sort of
walk you see that happen on like a
Thursday and by Friday they're trying to
jump out windows here too right they're
trying to jump out windows his favorite
thing is my mom in her kitchen I'm in my
parents house there's like a lazy susan
cabinet that has all you can and he
knows how to open it and climb inside
and then shifts at the back of the lazy
susan where I can't remove him it's
really smart and time yeah yeah they're
like baby Raptors do you miss being home
in New York City I mean you seem like a
guy who's supposed to be walking around
the streets of New York sort of in a
Woody Allen ask away yes you Chris
walking around only in the New York
resident Woody Allen desk wait let's be
clear on that
really we just started just like nodding
my head when you said it and then I
realized I should clear up the ways in
which yeah I resemble Woody Allen only
in that way but very specific walking
through New York with your tall handsome
friend that would be me from Annie Hall
and you know making quips about what's
happening
are you missing that life I do I loved
Jackson Heights it's it's the most
diverse neighborhood in the country they
say beautiful place beautiful people
what I miss most of all is raising my
kid there having him there for the first
year of his life I wouldn't trade it for
anything he kind of became almost like a
neighborhood celebrity because he's
really cute and I know every parent says
that but he is people will stop us
there's a restaurant on Northern
Boulevard in Queens we went to it and we
were seated and about a minute later an
older Hispanic lady on the other side of
the restaurant stood up and yelled
that's a great white baby and everybody
turned around and I was like I almost
fell I was like did I do something
racist like older Hispanic ladies love
babies they love them and they love my
baby that's a great white baby sure I
said that about him is one of the worst
things to specify the the race but I
guess whatever you know that's a great
white baby the panic the initial panic
like I did something racist was so
profound so I'm just trying to eat
I'm sorry about the whiteness what can I
do
yeah I mean look at me I had no option
at Kirstin with this now I'm curious a
lot of us are going through just changes
in our habits because we're now all
stuck at home I know I have again my
eating habits are shifting just because
I'm not going to work every day and
because I'm here with my family I'm kind
of eating what they are eating is that
happening with you yeah
100% I'm so much healthier my wife is
like really dedicated to her health and
now that we're eating all our meals
together I feel so much better
especially you remember being in New
York you just walk around you're like
should I get pizza or empanadas or like
everything's just in front of you and
your face yeah oh yeah for me I realized
the worst my eating habits got a couple
months ago this bakery opened up in my
neighborhood it was really good and it
was it was between the Train and my hat
so I had to walk past it all the time
and one night on my way home I stopped
in there and they were selling these
like creme brulee cups like in a tin you
know where they take it and put the
blowtorch right there anyhow I got to
get one so eating it on my way home and
then halfway there I was like creme
brulee is not like a grab-and-go item
you know like this is disgusting you
don't just this is not like a granola
bar at a bodega like you're supposed to
eat creme brulee twice a year when
someone else pays for it this is not OK
this is horrible and I actually I
finished it and threw it in the garbage
can at the end of my blocks I didn't
want my wife to know that I'm just like
oh horrific and that's the behavior of
an alcoholic like I got to get rid of
the bottle so my my spouse doesn't see
it just I would say maybe a week and a
half ago my wife made lunch for our son
and she put kale and chickpeas in a
blender for him a one-year-old and I sat
next to them and ate a bowl of Reese's
puffs cereal that was god bless you
you're keeping respect massive yeah yeah
she's teaching him how to be a healthy
living human and I'm teaching him how to
die younger than he asked you
I have a question that I'm very
interested in people have been telling
me about this thing called cameo where
you can get pay money to a celebrity and
a celebrity will make a message for you
right and it's really nice to you I've
seen a couple of them and I understand
that this is something you're doing now
yeah I'm doing cameo it's come to this
you know I had an HBO special a couple
years ago now I'm like selling people
birthday messages on an app it's fine
they have been emailing me about it for
a while and I was just avoiding and now
I'm like I lost you know all my touring
gigs for the years though yeah I'll tell
you you know congrats on your
anniversary for $35 a pop like I guess
I'm okay with that now it's actually
turned out pretty fun is that your rate
is it $35 it is it used to be 25 but
then I was poking around and there's a
this is very egotistical but I found
another comedian who I think is good
like but day I was at 25 and they were
at 35 and I was like they're not they're
not $10 better no way I just matched
there I was it cuz it's such a weird
thing when you cuz I didn't realize this
at first but they make you put an actual
monetary value on your own worth you
have to sit there go what am i worth
yeah when I saw this other comedian I
was like no way no way they're not
obviously you can't tell me who the
other comedian is no and they're great
there's someone I like but they're
anything ten dollars better I'm much
more experienced much more experienced I
can't do that for my self-esteem I would
think about it all day
oh that's like doesn't seem like it
feels like this is a good way for you to
earn some income right now it is it is
most of my income has come via this one
guy named Randy in Gainesville Florida
because he got Kovac and a friend of his
I guess he's a phantom on a friend of
his body cameo and then like two more
came in and I was like is this the same
Randy and then they all thought I was
funny so I got like 9 things telling
Randy to heal up and then he got out so
I got like 4 more to tell Randy Congrats
on getting out of hospital then he got
engaged so I got like two or three more
that were like can you congratulate
Randy and Jessica
Chris it was just Jessica's birthday so
Randy bought one so I've got that made
like a lot of money off this guy Randy
in Gainesville Chris yeah Hospital yeah
yeah you're not supposed to charge them
to get well all right your show is still
on the air mine got canceled okay my got
canceled like a year and they don't
think it's gonna make it and we'd love
it if you would say hang in there I'm
praying for you and you're like okay
where's my money I'm like 25 bucks and
do it fast cuz I'm bumping it up to 35
okay
I'm 35 any day now let's get it rolling
let's get it really
I saw one cameo that comes to mind I
think it was Todd bridges from facts of
life did a cameo where he wished someone
a happy birthday and I swear to God I
think he was standing in a very small
bathroom backed up against a Kurt like a
a plastic crinkled shower curtain yeah
most of mine are like this close to my
face it's just me like hey uh I heard
it's your birthday it stucks down
birthday during the quarantine yeah
Cecilia tells me you really love dogs
yeah sorry I know you're a big fan sorry
to hear that you've got weeks to live
but where's my money
he's getting married though he he
invited me he tweets at me now I feel
like I know this guy like I've learned
so much and say here's the ethical
question let's say you get invited to
the wedding that's a personal appearance
I will say this because you've made me
feel bad Randy if you see this not only
will I attend your wedding I am a
registered Reverend at the First Nations
ministry and I will be the Reverend at
your wedding - Jessica if you want for
35 dollars 35 more dollars yes and let's
do it in person please so cameo doesn't
get a cut of that one - okay yeah you
cut out the middleman
you don't need cameo I'll make sure I
get to this planets come live yeah airs
Wednesday nights at 10:00 on Twitch and
you can listen to Chris's podcast
beautiful
wherever you get your podcasts and
you're always a very funny guy and I
really enjoy talking to you and I'm glad
I know that you were in the epicenter
I'm glad you you and your family are
doing well yeah for sure thank you for
that and thank you for always for having
me and if I can just say there's a lot
of things out there GoFundMe ease
organizations that are helping Jackson
Heights at Elmhurst there's one that I
don't run it I contribute to it they
just buy food for the nurses and doctors
at Elmer so my neighborhood got hit hard
and it's a really beautiful place full
of beautiful people so I just want to
say you know the exact name of any of
those charities so we can put them at
the bottom no I'm a guy exploiting pain
on cammy I don't pay that much attention
but you can Google you know we're gonna
put up we're gonna we're gonna find out
and we're gonna put them up at the
bottom of the screen right now
so that would be awesome yeah right now
because those people are doing God's
work and Chris I love talking to you and
let's do this again soon under happier
circumstances
likewise I love it thank you for having
me you remain a true inspiration and I'm
psyched to get to see what a part of
your house looks like well this is it I
mean this is my parents bedroom and I
just realized there's been two
Tupperware containers in my shop I've
been eyeing those how sad no one's gonna
slam you for like showing off no one's
gonna slam me for showing off not a
fancy guy alright thank you very much
Chris Gethard